[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock as the clock ticks down to
christmas and hundreds of thousands of
people race to get their booster jab
before the year is out questions this
morning over whether we're in for a
gloomy start to the new year the deputy
prime minister and justice secretary
dominic ram on the programme this
morning will get his thoughts too on the
growing rebellion the prime minister is
facing later over a vote on plan b rules
we'll also get the view of a top
scientist who attends the government
sage meetings to ask how many
hospitalizations the new variant of
omicron may cause
also this morning for you we'll speak to
the trainee doctor who had to flee for
his life from afghanistan now saving
lives for the nhs good for him and
flying high will be talking to that
teenager aiming to become the youngest
to fly around the world she's currently
in taiwan
all of that to come tuesday 14th of
december
cues and concerns over booster target
and possible new year restrictions as
the prime minister faces a tory
rebellion over plan b rules
i'm in west london at one of the three
thousand sites across the uk some of
which will be open 24 7 to try and reach
that million jabs a day figure
omicron update at half past nine will
bring you live coverage of the former
head of the uk vaccine task force
revealing new information about the
variant
the young lives lost
a two-month-old girl among the victims
of the deadly us tornadoes as rescuers
continue to look for survivors
we'll have the latest from the town of
dawson springs it's four days since the
tornadoes swept through and still they
are accounting for the missing
and i'm here in moscow where the supreme
court is set to decide whether to
liquidate one of russia's oldest and
most important human rights organization
and what looks
very like another attempt to muzzle the
kremlin's critics
calling time on the wild west online the
new powers that could tackle senior tech
company managers to keep children safer
and back in the saddle peloton shares
recover after sex and the city wobble
we'll tell you more
[Music]
good morning everybody the race is on as
hundreds of thousands of people trying
to get their booster jams before the
year is out concerns this morning over
whether the government can hit its
target of jabbing nearly one million
people every single day questions too
over what might be coming in the new
year in terms of restrictions as omicron
infections continue to rise but
currently the number of people in
hospital with the new variant is low and
there has been one confirmed death all
that as the prime minister faces a
growing rebellion from his own mps
who'll vote later on plan b rules we'll
get the latest figures from the deputy
prime minister dominic raab in just a
few moments time
first let's take you through today's key
points should we they're looking
something like this omicron currently
infecting 200 000 people a day across
the uk we're told that's according to
modeling from the uk health security
agency
boris johnson said yesterday that half a
million booster jams were booked online
in 24 hours not including walk-ins
meanwhile the times reports that nhs
leaders fear they are being set up to
fail by the pm's promise of a million
jabs a day and a goal of offering all
adults a booster by the end of the month
boris johnson is also facing pressure
from his own back bench mps who are
preparing to vote against plan b which
includes expanding of mask wearing in
public places daily tests to avoid
self-isolation after contact
covered passes for large venues and
mandatory jobs for nhs workers our chief
political correspondent john craig
reports
a musical at the theater a christmas
tradition for many but from tomorrow
audiences at manchester's palace theatre
and entertainment venues all over
england will need a covered pass to
watch the show people here don't seem to
mind however
i'd rather protect other people and
myself
in all honesty and if we all just follow
it it's gonna be
a lot easier in the long run i think if
the system is right
and it shouldn't be a pain i think it'll
make queues long as well i think it'll
take a long time to get into venues now
but at westminster conservative mps are
threatening a major rebellion in votes
on boris johnson's plan b coveted
restrictions with the rebels bitterly
opposed to covet passes i think they are
further erosion of civil liberties i
think they're deeply damaging to our
economy and also i think it's a further
distraction from those other health
conditions that the pandemic has already
distracted us from
the rebellion could be bigger than the
prime minister's 80-seat commons
majority
today's votes on these new covered
regulations which run to 24 pages are
likely to see boris johnson suffer the
biggest tory rebellion since the general
election two years ago
the previous record was 54 rebels that
was on the tier system of covert
restrictions but today's revolt is
likely to be much bigger
it's never been part of our ethos in the
united kingdom to compel people by law
to become immunized
with the threat of a criminal sanction
if you don't and i think that we've got
to be very careful we don't set
precedents uh that are making people in
the country criminals in these areas
when it's really a public health issue
after the government warned that the new
omicron variant is currently infecting
200 000 people a day across the uk
the pm is today appealing for a
volunteer army to sign up to help
deliver his target of a million booster
jabs a day
24-hour vaccination centers and jabs on
christmas day planned
and with the pm refusing to rule out
further covert restrictions
many tory mps fear that if plan b is
approved today before long the
government may introduce a plan c
john craig sky news
well aisha's at a vaccine center in west
london for us this morning hi aisha my
goodness we've seen in the papers this
morning people snaking around these
vaccine centers waiting for hours and
hours and hours what are you hearing
about where you are and indeed whether
there might be any more restrictions
coming down the pike
yeah there really is a big sense of
urgency to get boosted amongst members
of the public lots of people at
vaccination clinics that yesterday spoke
about how important it was for them to
get their booster jabs before christmas
before they mix with friends and family
and of course christmas time is going to
be important to so many people
especially after there were restrictions
in place last year
and amid reports in the newspapers this
morning that we may see more
restrictions being introduced when it
comes to socializing by new years things
like the rule of six being reinforced
but in the meantime the main line of
defense does well and truly remain these
booster jabs there really is that big
push to get people boosted as soon as
possible here at this clinic in eling
they normally uh deliver 500 booster
jabs a day yesterday that number doubled
because of the number of walk-in
appointments that they did have
so over the next few weeks it's going to
be incredibly busy here as will be the
case up and down the country more pop-up
sites appearing military personnel being
drafted in to help the efforts and tens
of thousands of volunteers will also be
recruited but there are concerns today
in the times there's been reports that
nhs leaders are concerned over whether
they will be able to hit this one
million jabs a day target or not they
said to first of all increase capacity
that will be the big question whether
that can be done or not especially amid
staff shortages
okay aisha thank you thanks a lot
still to come on the program for you
this morning the uk health security
agency estimates omicron is infecting up
to 200 000 people per day will speak to
a professor from the institute of
immunology and immunotherapy at the
university of birmingham
we'll also speak to the olympic sprinter
ewan thomas who wants us all to get
outdoors and exercise during the festive
season
prime minister is facing a tory
rebellion over plan b restrictions we'll
speak to an mp who's urging the
government to drop the plans
that though um tragic news from the us
this morning a two-month-old girl among
more than
80 people eight zero people confirmed
dead
following a barrage of tornadoes that
devastated at least five u.s states
oakland there she is
oakland uh [ __ ] her name and her family
flung directly into the eye of a storm
when a tornado struck their kentucky
home among other victims nine-year-old
aniston rackley who died when a gale
lifted her from her back garden
and grandmother ollie borgman whose
house was ripped from its foundations
kentucky's governor has spoken about the
unspeakable trauma caused by the fatal
tornadoes the national guard is still
searching through the rubble but hopes
of finding more survivors are fading as
mark stone reports from dawson springs
in kentucky
the destruction here is hard to absorb
the flags are still flying but dawson
springs has been flattened
because here it isn't just the buildings
knocked over trees have been stripped
cars upturned it is the granular damage
the bits and pieces of people's lives
churned up carried hundreds of meters
the house at the end of elaine drive is
the simpson family home
we found wayne and his son picking
through what's left
this was their daughter's bedroom she
was away on friday night a twist of fate
and a blessing
but they were here they survived they
don't know how
the tv i think the
kind of the alarm of the
the tornado warning and all that
woke me up
uh trying to get to our pets and
everything he woke up and like i said we
got into the bedroom closet right before
it hit
and
if you look at what we have left
we're blessed this this house was well
built and we're just thankful that
that we're so blessed
not everybody had that opportunity
well i wish you both lots of luck thank
you thank you i'm sorry thank you thank
you very much thanks
randy norman is one of the responders
many of them are volunteers but they do
now have help from beyond for an awful
job
i'm trying to coordinate um
the recovery system right now uh
we have quite a few people missing
and uh so we're still trying to or you
can see
uh they could be anywhere so
uh going up into the heart of the
uh the destruction
wow really bad up here
this is pine street
and up at the end they were recovering
what they could among them joe loney
i woke up in the house was shaking i
hear that like a train coming loud
then the house got shaken violently when
a trailer hit my house it knocked me out
of bed and hurt my shoulder not moving
the floor when i did a two-pour come
through the wall
cut my hand right there
nick my forehead and went through behind
the shepherd behind me right across off
my bed what knocked me out of
yep i lived there for 26 years
and then 26 seconds is gone
these are the teams searching for the
missing this morning they found three
who didn't make it
this isn't the season for tornadoes like
this and yet it was they say the
strongest on record
the president will visit this week he's
promised whatever it takes
but how do you put all this back
together mark stone sky news in dawson
springs kentucky
as mark was
saying the sadly it does look as though
it's returning to a recovery position
now as a hope spade for anyone else
in the rubble of those tornadoes
um just want to bring you some breaking
news that's reaching us here at sky
centre it relates to job figures here in
the united kingdom and uh we are hearing
that they are up more people are um in
work it's not yet increasing to the rate
of
pre-pandemic at levels but we are
hearing from the office of national
statistics the director of economic
statistics
darren morgan telling us with still no
sign of the end of the furlough scheme
hitting the number of jobs the total of
employees on payroll continued to grow
strongly in november that's what he's
saying uh meantime the authorities in
russia want to close international
memorial uh one of the country's oldest
human rights organization
amnesty international says it would not
only muzzle the critics of the kremlin
but all independent voices in russia uh
let's bring in diana magnay our moscow
correspondent standing by for us diana
good morning to you good afternoon where
you are explain this to us
good morning k well it was a year which
started with alexey navalny's return
after he was poisoned with novichok and
prompt imprisonment and it may very well
end with the closure of
two very important human rights
organizations they both come under the
memorial umbrella memorial international
as you said um is there's a case being
heard in the supreme court behind me
today as to whether to liquidate
memorial international which has done
more than any other organization to
document uh the soviet-era repressions
the crimes of stalin's times to give the
victims names and to rehabilitate those
victims mostly posthumously and there is
a separate case brought by the
prosecutor general to look at memorial
human rights society which defends
against human rights abuses and
repressions in today's russia
and both of these organizations are
being charged under foreign agent
legislation which ironically is
precisely the label enemy of the state
effectively which all those people who
were executed and persecuted under
stalin and in soviets times were labeled
so this is possibly if the supreme court
hearing goes against or judgment goes
against memorial a very sad day
for human rights in russia after a very
very difficult year for
journalists for opposition figures and
for civil society in this country
okay thanks very much diana thank you
the victims of the disgraced former
doctor to the u.s gymnastics team larry
nasser are set to receive a share of 380
million dollars the settlement ends a
five-year legal battle that has rocked
us sport nasa was found guilty in 2018
of sexually abusing hundreds of gymnasts
and sentenced to more than 300 years in
jail
law is representing u.s citizen and
seculars so there is no agreement yet on
her attending a virtual hearing to be
held in the uk mr kulas was charged in
2019 with killing teenager harry dunn by
dangerous driving the family has been
told that mr kulas will face criminal
proceedings online and their
spokesperson has told sky news that
harry's parents still feel devastated
as always they're just full of strength
and determination and resilience but the
reality is away from
the tv cameras that they're absolutely
on their knees and and going through uh
understandably you know the most
incredibly difficult time and
i you know i just admire their their
fortitude it's absolutely remarkable to
me
emma adakano the us open champion is
isolating after being forced to withdraw
from an exhibition tournament in abu
dhabi after testing positive for kovit
19. she's one of the favorites to become
sports personality of the year on sunday
but
maybe isolating
a landmark report could help to cut down
on some of the most harmful online
content such as child abuse racist abuse
and videos which promote violence and
self-harm the report is recommending
changes to the online safety bill due to
go before parliament to make internet
service providers responsible for what's
on their platforms katie barnfield
reports
this is molly russell in happier times
at just 14 years old she took her own
life
her family struggled to understand why
then they found thousands of posts she'd
been looking at on sites like instagram
encouraging self-harm and suicide
i think that
social media helped kill my daughter
what social media's algorithms
showed molly increasingly
led her down a dark rabbit hole
from which
there wasn't really ever going to be an
escape and i know for a fact that the
the the platforms suggested molly
um saw more and more harmful content
molly's dad ian is one of those who gave
evidence to a committee of mps their
report published today recommends
sweeping changes to the online harms
bill coming before parliament next year
their recommendations include giving the
regulator ofcom more powers to
investigate and find social media
companies that don't address harmful
content
forcing providers to conduct risk
assessments including looking at the
impact of their own algorithms
and creating new criminal offences like
making cyber flashing and content
promoting self-harm illegal they say
stricter regulations should also be used
to reduce the spread of disinformation
like anti-vaccine posts with false
claims about the dangers of getting a
jab it feels like the problems have got
worse so the system of self-regulation
they created for themselves has clearly
failed they may not have created this
content but their systems are hosting it
their systems are recommending it to
people and therefore they have a
responsibility to act against it as well
meta that owns facebook instagram and
whatsapp told sky news it already has
strict policies in place but welcomes
more regulation
the government now has two months to
respond to the report and says it will
consider the recommendations carefully
tech companies have to behave
differently they have to change their
corporate culture for people like ian
whose lives have been scarred by harmful
content change can't come soon enough
katie barnfield sky news
now anybody who is affected by the
topics in our report or is emotionally
distressed can contact the samaritans of
course for support have a look at the
number on the bottom of your screen one
six
one two three that's the helpline number
or via email um joe
samaritans.org we'll just leave that
there for a second for you that if
you're feeling such a challenging time
of year isn't it especially with what's
going on at the moment helpline 116 123
or if you prefer to email them joe
samaritans.org
now let's um have a look at these
pictures from la palma as we say the
volcano still erupting angrily and
creating rivers of lava snaking their
way down the island the eruption which
has been going for nearly three months
is the longest running on the spanish
canary islands since records began in
1500 air quality is still poor but
yesterday for the first time in days
students were able to leave school at
the regular
time it doesn't look as though she's
giving up yet though does it
a quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
entering a fairly mild settled a mostly
dry spell although the northwest will be
wet and very windy today bright but
chilly for many northern parts with a
patchy frost northwest scotland is wet
and windy
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
deputy prime minister is with us mr rob
good morning
thanks for joining us uh let's start
with the stats should we give us an
update on the number of people
who are in hospital with omicron i don't
know the precise figures but we do know
um that we've had the first deaths there
has been an increase
and above all we're concerned about the
rate of transmission uh the the positive
side uh that we do believe and again the
information on omicron is is still
sketchy but if people get their third
jab they're over 70 protected and so
we've currently got over 40 of adults
with their booster with their third jab
the big push is now by the end of the
year to get people that booster that is
the surest way we protect ourselves
while we find out a bit more about the
real impact of omicron you said death's
plural
how many i i'm not sure of the uh the
prime minister told us one yesterday
that's that was my understand that's the
latest figures i know that there have
been so it's not plural it's one again
all i can tell you is the latest uh that
i've seen uh in terms of plural i was
referring to uh we now know we've got a
significant number in hospital okay how
many are on ventilators i don't know uh
the latest facts i think and do we know
the person that died did they die with
omicron or because of it i think it's uh
often very difficult to say uh because a
lot of people have uh
combined conditions if you like uh
particularly if they're they're old so i
don't know the answers and the truth is
okay just to be very honest we don't
know the full severity what we do know
is that the rate of transmission is so
rapid that even if the severity is
relatively low compared to other
variants that we've seen just because of
the numbers we need to take action now
which is why what the government is
doing today i believe is a targeted
proportionate approach as we find out
more come on to that i just wanted the
data check to start with which is very
helpful for our viewers you said a
significant number in hospital how many
well the last i saw was uh in the low
hundreds uh i think 250 the last time i
looked but of course the data is being
uh updated 250 out of 200 000 people who
contracted it yesterday that's still a
very small number the problem is the
rate at which
it is transmitting
and if that continues we'll see those
numbers uh increase
very dramatically and then we know a
proportion of those hospitalized
will have a uh possibly die or have a
very serious uh uh suffering of of the
omar conveyor as a result of that you
want people to get jabbed as quickly as
possible how many people were jabbed
yesterday
i don't know yesterday but i know we're
up to 41
who have been uh triple jabbed on
saturday we got half a million uh get
their booster so that's why we want
everyone by the end of this month so by
the end of the year uh over 18 to be
offered that chance to get a booster and
again the the i missed the sketchiness
of what we have deciphered about omicron
uh we know that you're over 70 likely to
be protected if you from from it if you
get that third boost okay good job so
you want a million people a day to be
jabbed including on christmas day um
half a million or so uh yesterday i
believe if those are the figures that
we're normally looking at people waiting
for five hours in the cold what are they
going to wait 10 hours well no the look
i appreciate as we've ramped up
this campaign and people have come
forward which is good we want them to
come forward we know that there's been
a challenge particularly getting the
online booking it's the same for lateral
flow tests we're dealing with that we're
making sure that we've got the capacity
the walk-in centers bear in mind that
at least up until wednesday this
wednesday the offer had been to those 30
year old or above but from wednesday if
you're 18 year olds or 18 year old or
above you can book online the walk-in
centers are there uh we've deployed uh
various teams of military personnel to
really ramp this up i appreciate that
with all these things as you introduced
in that pace there'll be some teething
issues but we are uh ramping this up at
pace and it's good news
is the british public are ready
absolutely and you weren't
well look this is a rapid reaction
to a variant of over which we are
gleaning more information every day but
we are going to be ready we've ramped up
the plans the military involved the
jab's army the volunteers are supporting
the nhs staff and we've got the centres
and we're boosting the capacity to deal
with um the volume of people but as i
said the the the shift is being from
wednesday the ability to book if you're
over 18 not just over 30. why did you
not do that earlier
we're responding to this as swiftly as
we can in real time it's a a challenging
logistical operation but we've got the
capacity to do this and as i said we're
straining every sinew from the military
to the volunteers to the nhs staff to do
this
given that will everybody who wants
someone be able to get a job by the 31st
of december well look we
everyone yes or no question well
it is i mean you're telling me how
fabulous that all this work is the offer
will be yours so everybody who wants a
job will be able to have one we're doing
everything to get as many people as we
possibly can uh jabbed uh and of course
uh we're starting from now i think it's
41 who've had the booster uh we've got
that capacity we're ramping up and we
want to get as close to uh that as
possible but look the offer is what the
target is to get everyone over 18
offered um that booster but no guarantee
look we'll do everything we can we we're
straining every scene you you know we've
got that capacity up but the good news
is we got half a million people um per
day getting that boost and every time we
hit that with a day that's uh half the
million people with 70 protection 70
plus from omicron that's good news so
one of the ways to get people through
quicker is to get rid of the 15 minute
observation time once you've had your
booster what are you going to do about
that well i think if we did that and uh
you can always look at things like that
you'd get people concerned about um any
potential side effects which are only
for a small minority um i mean i
remember sitting there 15 minutes and
being champing at the bit to get get off
but i think
i think the nhs do want to make sure we
just look after and keep an eye on
anyone that might have a side effect
even if it's a very few small number of
people
so there's no guarantee and i understand
what you're saying there's no guarantee
31st of december that everybody will
have had the job even those who want to
even those who that want to stand out in
the cold when then
will we find ourselves in a position
where uh fully vaxxed means three jobs
well
sorry i'm not sure i quite understand
that at the moment you have to in order
to um have a passport you have to have
two jobs you were saying no that you
have to have three jobs at what stage
well i think let's gauge how far we get
we want to make sure of course we've got
the everyone who wants to have that jab
uh the opportunity uh and so we haven't
got a definitive timeline and of course
i'm reading this morning that um it's
february is that not right uh i don't
think a decision has been made it's
certainly not been set out and of course
it's not just that a reasonable time
february well
obviously what we want to do is get as
many uh people with the booster as
possible and that would make it i think
um easier to introduce that but of
course even if you haven't had um the
double jab or in due course the booster
you can still rely on the lateral flow
test which is why i think some of these
concerns about this are overstated in my
view because i think if you're going
into a crowded place um i would
personally want to for my own safety but
also for those around want to make sure
that i either had a lateral flow test or
or i was um
double and due course triple jabbed so
i've on my travel passport at the moment
i have because i've had the booster it's
got all three uh registered on there
that's not necessarily going to be the
case you won't necessarily need all
three to show that you have been fully
vaxxed
well at the moment the rules are double
jab i understand what the rules are for
a lateral flow test yeah and of course
it'll depend if we look ideally we'd get
everyone triple vaxxed and that would be
that is the best way um because of
course the lateral flow tests are a
pretty reliable but not 100 percent
reliable the best way is to get back
selected for short how are you feeling
about vaccine passports
look i i think it's a difficult thing to
do i do understand the concerns people
have but i think it's necessary i think
people want to see us grappling with the
omicron there in a sensible targeted
proportional way you you talked about
people feeling uneasy i know in other
interviews i've done they've said the
same thing i think we want to provide
that reassurance and i think this is a
proportionate way of doing so okay the
reason i mention it is because uh tory
backbencher marcus fish this is his
quote i don't know how my viewers will
feel about it i'm interested how you
will we live in a free society in this
country where people have the freedom to
do what they want with their own bodies
and freedom of association we are not a
papers please society this is not nazi
germany it's the thin end of an
authoritarian wedge
how do you feel about this government
being compared to nazi germany um i'm
afraid i don't accept that but i know
marcus very well and i know he's got a
strong passion and uh he feels very
strongly about it's offensive uh liberty
look if if you want to invite me to
criticize people
uh i want you to my viewers this morning
will say that is offensive especially
and look i don't accept it and i don't
think it's right and i don't think it's
uh a reasonable critique but i do
understand the concerns that people have
but all i would say as i said before is
you you know
either you can demonstrate that you've
had you've been double jabbed or that
you've taken an actual flow test i don't
think that is a particularly intrusive
thing to do in order that we can all
protect not just ourselves but those
around us in the limited number of
crowded destinations or venues that this
applies to we're talking about i think
it's 500
indoor over 500 people indoor over 4 000
outdoors i mean this is just i think a
sensible precautionary public health
measure that will protect us all at
least 79 of marcus vicious colleagues
agree with him though perhaps not
phrasing it quite the same and they are
going to vote against uh the government
proposition today how do you feel about
labour having to prop you up again well
look i don't think it's going to be the
case that they will have to prop us up
but the fact of the matter is
well i'm not sure you're right well i've
done lots of these votes before and you
get these numbers banded around the
media and actually have a debate and one
of the things you do in debate is you
listen to the other side but do you
think that's important listen
respectfully to the other side and i
hope the government um uh will be
listened to as well we'll make our case
and i'll be very surprised if the number
is as high as you describe but the
bottom line is the business of
government is doing what's right for the
country
and that's what we'll do what if it is
as high as that
i look you can ask i don't know about
hypothetical questions the reality is
the government must do what it sensibly
believes is right in the interest of the
country i believe these are
proportionate measures coupled with the
big surge in the effort to get people
boosted before christmas i think that's
the right approach yeah but given that
and if there is a rebellion perhaps not
as high as 80 perhaps 79 that will mean
that you will have to look very closely
at wider restrictions and those are just
not going to come down the pie can or
are they i don't think i think we'll i
think we'll get these measures through i
think uh i think a lot of you will
because people will support you well and
i think the number one focus is on the
booster campaign
because it gives us you that extra
efficacy against the omicron variant and
of course it's a temporary thing uh
because we need to find out more we
still got a fairly relatively sketchy
sense of how dangerous omicron is i
understand those who say well there's no
um you know that we don't know the full
impact understand that i think what
we've got to do as government is to take
a precautionary balanced approach to
stop the worst implications and
precisely because you you know in three
weeks time i'd be on this show and you'd
be saying to me why didn't you act more
swiftly we are acting more swiftly but
we're doing so in a proportionate way
um deputy prime minister are we looking
at any further restrictions we've got no
plans but the plan is for plan b coupled
with the vaccine
booster uh surge in making that
available and helping people no further
restrictions in the pipeline
the one thing we know about this time
look the the no there's a plan b um
who knows whether there'll be another
variant along the line but we're
learning more about the virus
every day we've got this omicron variant
which has uh uh created a different set
of challenges but we're getting to grips
with that and we've got plan b and we
think it's the right one so we won't be
paying for a good christmas then we
won't be paying for a good christmas
you'll have a lovely christmas but
you'll bring new reels in uh very early
in the new year look i think people can
go into this christmas enjoy it um we've
got an opportunity to spend time with
loved ones in a way that we didn't last
year and at the same time i do think
it's right to encourage people to get
the booster um vaccine absolutely and
and we'll go no further restrictions are
in the pipeline
look we've got none planned given this
variant as a result of this variant
there's no further restrictions in the
pipeline the plans are the plan b with
the masks in the settings that i
described um
encouraging people to think about
whether they need to go to work if they
if they can work from home if they can
and it's the right thing to do and yes
we've got to take these other measures
in relation to particularly crowded
places indoor outside that coupled with
the vaccine booster campaign is where
all our focus is okay i just want to ask
you uh about um the european court of
rights before i let you go almost out of
time bill doesn't act the bill that
you're talking about doesn't actually
affect citizens rights to seek redress
does it at the european court of human
rights so so what does it actually do
we'll do three things uh first of all
we've got a proud tradition of freedom
in this country we'll strengthen the
quintessentially british rights like
freedom of speech the liberty that
guards all of the others we have seen
that whittled away recently for various
reasons secondly we can prevent some of
the abuses of human rights that people
care about the ability of people to
scupper deportation orders who have been
convicted of serious offences and
thirdly one of the things i think people
see is the goalposts shift on human
rights and expand incrementally that uh
ought to be subject to democratic
oversight by lawmakers like me
accountable to your viewers and those
are the three big things i think we can
achieve take forward our tradition of
freedom in this country i need christmas
parties planned at dining street this
year do you know uh none that i'm
invited to
doesn't mean there aren't any it's good
to talk to you as always thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you
let's have a quick look at what's
happening as far as the papers are
concerned nhs overwhelmed
the telegraph reporting as it attempts
to deliver government pledges on booster
jabs
the guardian says the national health
service has been put on a crisis footing
as hospitals in england told to
discharge as many patients as possible
the eyes flashes with britain's race to
get boosted as the nhs aims to give out
a million third doses a day by the end
of the year
the metro pleads with its readers to
sign up to the ome army and get the jab
the sun leads with its jabs army
campaign hoping to recruit 30 000
volunteers to help britain reach its
vaccination target
privilege to have kate with us this
morning kate good morning what did you
make of what the deputy prime minister
had to say i think there were a couple
of really good things in that he said
really clearly dominic robb that there
is still a sketchy sense of what omicron
means for the country and that's the
biggest problem in all of this because
without actual data it becomes very
difficult for the government to make the
argument to their backbenchers and of
course you talked about the size of that
rebellion i thought it was quite
interesting that the deputy prime
minister said he didn't think that there
would be a rebellion on that scale he
said it was overstated that might
actually annoy some of those
conservative mps i think i've come back
to bite him i think well that's when i
heard him say that i thought you may
live to regret that because some
conservatives right now feel the
government is taking them for granted
and they don't like the way that they
think boris johnson has behaved in
relation to christmas parties they are
frustrated any incendiary remark could
tip some of them into voting against
instead of abstaining and i think that's
the unknown we don't know how many will
actually vote against later but the
bigger point in all of this and all of
your questions around you know how many
people are in hospital what is the
actual impact of this is about the
country and how people feel and without
that data it's really hard for the
government to go to them and say
reliably we've got the right course of
action and that's why there are these
questions about further restrictions
will we need more what's it going to be
like in the new year and the problem is
without that data you can't answer them
i think it's a watching brief there are
still some hope in government that this
actually will have less severe symptoms
and that people may recover more quickly
that you may be able to avoid that
hospital overwhelmed nhs problem that we
had last year but that's the unknown and
without that data i mean it's all up for
grabs over the course of the next
fascinating stuff thanks a lot for that
kate thank you
let's bring in professor paul moss
should we from the institute of
immunology and immunotherapy at the
university of birmingham hello thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning how concerned are you given what
we've been hearing from the deputy prime
minister this morning about omicron
overwhelming the nhs
yeah it's fascinating nice to be with
you
um it's interesting as a scientist at
all the political discussions now about
viral infection viral immunology i
thought that's a very interesting
discussion
i think uh of course we're concerned
because the rate of spread is so
remarkable as you said yourself 200 000
cases but the great unknown is the
severity here and we just don't really
know that yet but you've seen that the
data from south africa does still
suggest one month in relatively milder
infection and that's really what we've
got to hope for
uh
how much can we be i mean because we
when we first heard from the south
african scientists the concern about
omicron we were very quick to react so
we obviously take at face value what
they're telling us
what are they actually telling us about
what's happening in south africa now as
you said more infections but less
harmful
what is that translating to fewer people
in hospital fewer people on ventilators
and
uh hopefully fewer deaths
still seems to be this case okay yes i
mean this virus probably appeared around
the 7th of november it's over a month
now and we know that this two or three
week delay between infection and death
so that's where everyone has to be very
very cautious but so far yes less
hospitalizations and less deaths we
heard from professor karim yesterday
talking about in south africa in
previous ways of the admissions which is
only a small percentage around two out
of three was so very severe whereas now
it's one out of four of admissions so so
far there does seem to be indications of
mild disease and that's encouraging and
let's hope that that translates to the
uk as well
what about the efficacy of previous
boosters we're dashing now to get
everybody their third booster as quickly
as we possibly can there was some
concern that potentially astrazeneca on
reflection has not been as good at
dealing with these variants as um
things like moderna and pfizer have been
yeah i think we now know that two
vaccines
is just not enough in terms of
protection against infection with this
omicron two is not enough and that's
where the boost is absolutely vital so
the data so far suggests that um this
omicron can resist about you know 20 or
40 fold of the antibodies that you've
made it takes your antibody level down
from 100 to between two and five percent
and that's with both vaccine types
really but after a booster you can
increase those antibodies again perhaps
20 or 30 fold again that's why we need
to boost is to get the antibody levels
again and if you've had a z and then you
get the mrna boost you're in a good
position
but wasn't that the same with delta why
are we so concerned about this one is it
because it spreads so quickly because i
had two uh booster i had two vaccines
and then i got the delta variant
well i mean this even with a booster i'm
afraid we're still going to see omicron
infections that's for sure we know that
these vaccines although they're
incredibly protective against severe
disease and death are not so great
against infections so there will be some
breakthrough infections but in terms of
severity it's simply that omicron is so
relatively resistant to our current
immune profile that the boosters are now
so critical
um a million infections uh is the
prediction by some
by the end of this month which is only
really a couple of weeks away or so
are you that pessimistic
well as you said to mr rob yourself
maybe two hundred thousand already so i
think we have to consider that as a
possibility yes um it is it is
disappointing the modeling is a little
bit uncertain and the wave within south
africa is uncertain how that will go as
well so it looks as if this new variant
will replace delta but we don't entirely
know yet but that's certainly a
possibility
what does the government need to do to
try to control this uh latest variant uh
we're we're talking about masks of
course uh some suggestions that there
should be um further limits when it
comes to hospitality
you had a very good discussion with him
didn't you 15 minutes ago and i think
it's entirely it's absolutely right that
we should stick to what has started so
yesterday we had working from home so
people need to do that wherever possible
of course masks we know are 50 effective
in reducing infections hands and so
forth use of lateral flows and we've
seen those really come into their own
and so forth so it's absolutely vital
that we stick to that and people will
make decisions about their own
hospitality events in the next few weeks
so i think we'll perhaps see some
behavioral change there i think we're
very fortunate the health security
agency is really on top of this and
their reports daily have been excellent
and if we do need any more
we will be able to act quickly
final thought professor what do you say
to those who say this is the normal life
of a virus we're very concerned about it
to start with then we see a variant
which is of equal concern but as we move
along with the variants they become
less impactful on the population
there's a lot of scientific debate as to
whether a virus evolves to become less
pathogenic less severe it's not entirely
sure that that's the case actually and i
think with omicron we just didn't know i
mean this could have been incredibly
infectious and also very very severe we
were at the mercy of the virus and if it
does turn out to be
less severe then that's very fortunate
so yeah i mean
let's hope so there are various
scenarios here from really awful to
potentially being some advantages if
this is a much milder but
virus but gives us some immunological
protection so as your colleague just
said a minute ago there's still a lot of
uncertainty
when should we know professor
um it's less than three weeks since i
first heard about this we've learned a
lot since that time i think by christmas
we will know an awful lot about the
severity of this disease in in
around the world yes
good to talk to you professor thanks for
your expertise as always thank you very
much
no it's uh we'll bring you the data on
the latest uh figures a little bit later
on in the programme
but it's now thought spinning can cause
um sudden death or at least
that's what uh sex and the city's
spin-off would have you think
but was it all a ruse
should we take another ride
life's too short not too
and just like that the world was
reminded that regular cycling stimulates
and improves your heart lungs and
circulation reducing your risk of
cardiovascular diseases cycling
strengthens your heart muscles lowers
resting pulse and reduces blood fat
levels he's alive
peloton released that cheeky ad after
their share price dropped by 11
following mr pig's on-screen death on
the first episode of and just like that
the fan favorite died of a heart attack
following an intense spinning session
prompting the actor ryan reynolds to
declare that he is indeed still alive
and later this morning we'll take a
closer look at hotel quarantine with
linda gillen she contacted me actually
earlier in the week she is currently in
hotel quarantine after she came home
from south africa
[Music]
now new research suggests that half of
us just don't have the motivation to go
outside in winter because it's just too
cold frankly a new campaign is trying to
change that and get us out to enjoy the
great outdoors this festive season even
if it's just for half an hour the
olympic sprinter you and thomas is
backing the idea and he's with us now hi
you and thanks very much indeed uh for
joining us how often do you manage to
get out in the wintertime
well i have to walk my dog or i should
say i like walking my dog at least once
a day he'd have two walks if he could
get his way but um i still run as well i
try to keep fit and i think for me it's
for my mind as well of course physically
it's very good to keep fit i think
certainly this time of year when it is a
bit gloomy and it can be quite
depressing when you look outside and
it's dark and it's dark by four or five
o'clock it's good to get out there and
and exercise the mind as well and for me
doing even as you said just a half an
hour walk a day because there's so many
beautiful roots on our doorstep that we
probably don't even know are there it's
good it's a brilliant thing to do
so what you're saying is we need more
than um uh 10 minutes after we've had
our christmas lunch
i would say so but listen 10 minutes is
better than nothing i mean when i when i
was an athlete i actually
loved to go out and train on christmas
day purely because i knew my rivals
wouldn't do that for me that gave me a
psychological edge but as i said for me
now i'm retired i have to keep fit
otherwise i would just become a couch
potato and i don't want to do that and
it's good for my mind as well there's
many times when i look outside and i
think i can't be bothered to go for a
walk it doesn't look great the weather's
not lovely but i always come back
feeling much better when than when i set
off so that's what i'd say even if you
can only afford 10 minutes a day half an
hour a day whatever you can do get out
there it's a lovely thing to do with the
family as well with your kids with your
pets get out keep active it's brilliant
yeah and of course footballers don't
they they all exercise on they train on
christmas day don't they because they
have boxing day matches
yeah most sports people will train uh
christmas day or throughout that festive
period and the good thing is as i said
earlier there's there's roots on your
doorstep you may not think are there
ordnance server they've got a fantastic
app you can download and users can
actually upload routes that they found
so there's thousands and thousands of
routes on your doorstep you probably
don't know were there so some people
might think oh i'm bored of doing the
same old walk listen i can guarantee
there will be different beautiful walks
right outside your front door without
you probably knowing they're there so
get out there take in the crisp winter
air it doesn't matter if it's cold put a
hat on put a scarf on and i guarantee
you'll feel better for doing it
i was just about to ask you what's your
top tip for what to wear i always say to
the family be girl be bold start cold
there you go just just keep dry i think
for me i don't like feeling wet that's
the only thing i don't mind feeling a
little bit cold because you're going to
warm up the further you walk and if you
want maybe turn the walk into a jog but
i think just keep keeping yourself dry
that's the main thing amazing okay it's
good to talk to you you and enjoy your
christmas thanks for joining us
thank you kai and you thank you thank
you
now after several southern african
countries were put on the government's
travel red list because of the omicron
variant returning travelers have been
forced to stay in quarantine hotels and
many not happy joined by linda gillan
who is currently in a quarantine hotel
near gatwick after traveling back to the
uk from south africa you wrote to me i
know linda earlier in the week didn't
you how are you getting one
i'm sorry i don't know i can't hear you
just at the moment linda say that again
i think um human beings have all fasted
millions and i think
okay linda we've got a little problem
listening to you do you have your hand
over the the speaker on the phone can
you just sort of be careful are you
holding it
can you do that
there we go i can hear you know
there we go how are you coping
i'm i'm coping better than i did i mean
it's been a nightmare from um prior to
even coming to the hotel and what amazes
me is there's one death with um omicron
um and all the overreaction um i've
spoken to many people in south africa
and they are
taking it in their stride living quite
normally they wear masks all the time
outside they are sanitized regularly
they really um
accept social distancing and observers
so it's been a nightmare from from start
to now really um
what happened was the airlines all shut
down immediately so we couldn't get
through to them on the phone they it
referred to their website which to refer
to the phone so it was a it was a
nightmare trying to coordinate covert
hotels with the flights
um the flight was then okay and they did
change the flight three times in one day
people were pacing at the um gates
because they were so frightened of not
being able to get back
um real absolute fear
and then the flight as i say was good um
when we landed we waited for two hours
in a freezing cold bus possibly caught
cold
then we waited for another two hours at
the hotel checking in
in gateway
and after that we were told we had to
have security to escort us outside your
previous um speak person on on you know
on this was saying that high important
exercises now i'm slightly
claustrophobic i needed to get outside
nobody was answering the telephone i
tried for four hours and eventually gave
up um the following day i told her
actually i said to the guard outside we
have guards outside our doors
yeah that i had to get out so he
contacted him
and i'm so sorry we are out of time so
we're just going to have to leave it
there but thank you for highlighting
some of the challenges that you are
facing in your hotel room and hopefully
you will be released very soon um thanks
for writing to me as well and hopefully
um having a chat on the telly has helped
with your mental health as well we're
back at the top of the hour do stay
tuned
[Music]